good afternoon my name is Howard Jacob
and I want to welcome you to this
webinar on the use of whole genome
sequencing in clinical practice I am
currently at the Medical College of
Wisconsin and I direct the human and
molecular genetic center I know we're
going to have people coming in and
joining on this call as well as the
webinar later on so for those of you
that are listening live I want to
encourage you to be able to text you
questions in as part of the web webinar
directions you've got and then the team
will make sure that we're ready to go
with that at the end of the seminar so
with that I'm going to step forward and
start off with a little bit of
information about what are we doing at
the medical college and where we're
going but before I do that I want to
start off with acknowledging the people
that I work with I'm privileged to be
able to tell you about a project that
involves a lot of people and you'll
notice on the slide a whole host of
people there's three things I want you
to get from the slide first of all it's
a team effort second of all there's
really only three physicians that are
involved in this entire program the rest
of the people are not clinicians and the
third pit is is everybody in the middle
of our informatics driven and I think
the key point to think about this is
that there's a tremendous number of
people involved with computers and
analysts that's going to be involved as
we move more and more down the road of
personalized medicine so again thanks to
my team and thank you again for for
joining alright so the overview of what
I want to discuss today is what is
personalized medicine i'm going to
define what i mean by personalized
medicine and why i use the term
personalized medicine rather than other
terminology that's used to categorize
this space some people don't think of it
as being personalized they think of it
as being a precision medicine or
something else but i'm going to be very
clear why i call personalized as we go
through i'm going to define the promise
and the current opportunity of
personalized medicine we're going to
talk some about the ethics
delivery a lot around the delivery of
personalized medicine at least how we're
practicing it here at the Medical
College of Wisconsin and we're going to
use some cases as illustrations as we go
through on those okay so personalized
medicine there's a tremendous number of
definitions out there this is my
favorite one its products and services
that leverage the science of genomics
and proteomics either directly or
indirectly in capitalize on the trends
towards wellness I think that's a very
key point wellness and on consumerism
again a very key point consumerism to
enable tailored approaches to prevention
and care the other part that I think is
fascinating about this is that this is a
definition that comes from an accounting
firm PricewaterhouseCoopers and I think
that that tells us a little bit about
how deep this is going to end up being
when accounting firms are starting to
think about what is personalized
medicine they're predicting that it's
going to have a huge impact on medical
care and I'm going to argue that
consumerism is going to be a major
driver and the evidence of that is the
direct-to-consumer genetic testing
that's already happening and is looking
to expand in fact we're both we're all
going to be hearing about 23andme as TV
commercials as they start launching
those nationally this fall okay so
personalized medicine I think this is a
slide that illustrates the diversity in
the human species is here we've got a
shack and patrica and you can take a
look at these two individuals and we
know that they're ninety-nine point nine
percent identical um but have huge
phenotypic differences in them and the
other part that I think is important is
is that it's not that our physicians
don't practice personal medicine of
course when they're working with us it's
personal but the tools we give them are
epidemiological and I like to use a
basic silly illustration of what I mean
by that so both Shack and a patrica have
a headache and they go to the medicine
cabinet and they read the directions and
that says adult take two aspirins well
we know that they both shouldn't take
the same amount or aspirin he should
probably take four and she may only take
one but epidemiologically we report that
on average it's two aspirins and so
that's the main point I want to make
one part of personalized medicine is we
want to move away from on average the
second part that I think is important is
the decisions that the leech have to
make around their own genome and that
will be a recurring theme that I go
through as we talk some more around this
the other part about this there's a lot
of people who say you know what
personalized medicine and reading
genomes is really not that relevant
that's not going to be that important
and I'm going to argue that at a
baseline it's going to be a better
family history and I'm going to argue
that today family history is how we
practice genetics in the clinic every
single day and most people would view
family history as being important so ask
yourself this question do you think
family history is important now you may
or may not but I'm sure you all fill out
those forms when you go into a new
physicians office about your family
history and what's very very clear if
you go in and look at some of the
literature around family history is that
there's a whole big set of problems
associated with family history and so
this paper I think it's kind of
interesting because it reports that men
under report significance I don't think
that should necessarily be a surprise
the other thing that they have
discovered is that men have half as many
relatives as women and I'm sure if you
stop and think about that for a moment
you'll realize that in many many
families my family included the woman in
the relationship manages both sides of
the family many men don't know who all
the relatives are so the lack of ability
to remember underreporting and then the
fact that we actually don't share this
type of information amongst Americans
very readily I can't speak for other for
other nationalities but most of the time
people don't have these discussions we
don't talk about what drugs we take we
don't talk about when do we take and we
don't talk about why do we take them so
I'm going to argue and a minimum genome
sequencing is a quantitative family
history that should improve every year
and how would we get to that how would
we look at that well one place to go is
to look at the genome-wide Association
studies and this is an old slide there's
been many more traits that have been put
on top of that and those of you there in
the audience that are listening are
going to be saying yeah but
Howard we all know that these have very
minimal effects in fact there's such a
small effect that they're really not
meaningful again this is on a population
level and I just want to remind you
about a couple of points and the one
that I like most is an analogy is that
salt also epidemiologically has no
impact on blood pressure but we know
that in many cases for hypertension self
does have a major impact and I just want
you to keep that in mind so I would
argue that if you have a snip that's
been shown to be associated with the
disease and a reported family history
maybe we should think about them and I
think we're going to see more and more
data around us in fact there's been a
pretty nice publication that's come out
of 23andme that talks about how this
information can be integrated with
family history the other part up here's
the [ __ ] here's a slide i forgot that i
put that in this is the paper i'm
talking about and i think this is a good
read it goes in and talks about where
these different diseases are and where
they can be used and i'll talk some more
about this as we go through the process
the other area of course that people
talk about is using genetic information
to help with Pharma pharmacogenomics I
again think this will be a big example
down the road and people will use it for
this here's the example of a clitoral
which is a commonly used drug it's all
it's a trade name as plavix and this
drug is known that between fifteen and
twenty four percent of the people that
take this medication our poor
metabolizers are unable to metabolize
this drug and this information is not
typically used clinically even though
it's recommended and one of the big
reasons around us both for the family
history snip information which people
aren't sure about and even in the cases
for drugs there's a major driver that
prevents this and the fact is that
genetic testing for diagnosis and drugs
is largely not used and often excluded
from insurance plans and that really
starts to have an impact on how we think
about practicing medicine so I want you
to think about that for a moment I know
these are the big issues i'm going to
walk you through some clinical cases
about how we are being able to use this
and i will finish up and talking about
how
we are actually getting reimbursement
for some of these types of tests so I
will come back to that as we go forward
but I want to now move you into how we
got involved in using whole genome
sequencing for a clinical tests we do
offer it as a clinical tests we have
both in a dark clinic and a pediatric
clinic that focuses on using whole
genome sequencing as part of our
diagnostic routine so I'll talk about
how we got there so the next slide is a
picture of nick Volker Nick Walker was
to at the time some of you may have
heard about this story some of you may
not have Nick was a healthy little
two-year-old boy and then all of a
sudden things started to go wrong and I
was not involved in the case early on
but I did get an email from Allen mayor
in July of 2009 Allen was the pediatric
GI specialist who was working with Nick
and this is the actual email that he
sent to me that said if you look down in
the bottom paragraph down here it says
briefly Nick I can now tell you his name
was a four-year-old boy with a very
unusual malignant form of inflammatory
bowel disease and profound delayed wound
healing he first presented with weight
loss and perry abscesses Imzadi downward
spiral for over two years he was
admitted in January mind you that this
is july twenty seventh with a
life-threatening breakdown of his
intestines and they've been trying to
keep him alive so long story short Allen
asked could we sequence his genome and
figure out what was wrong with them we
at the time looked into this and the
best we could do would be whole exome
sequencing which was going to cost just
for the right lab work about 75 thousand
dollars so we ended up figuring out how
to do that and we set out on this
mission to be able to do that and the
first thing of course we ran into was
how do you manage the data and in the
case of an exome it's going to be about
18,000 variants for an individual and
I'm just going to walk you through some
of the activities that we went through
but this is what Nick looked like it for
doesn't look nearly as healthy as he did
it too and the question was what do we
do with this what's wrong with this
trial so one of the things you have to
be able to do then is
to look at prioritization sir this is
actually the data from Nick how do you
come down and look at this so he had
16,000 124 variants we went through a
series of decisions protein-coding
nonsynonymous typical things that you
would stop to that you wouldn't
necessarily do any different than we
would do and the part that was important
is that since it's a rare disease it
needed to be absent from other reference
genomes we came down to two genes one
was gstm1 transferase and the other was
xiap long story short we were able to
exclude gstm1 and focus on xiap if we
have geneticists in the audience you are
aware that xiap is X an inhibitor of
apoptosis and this gene has been
reported previously to play a role in a
disease process that if it's this gene
is damaged patients will die if they get
a infection from epstein-barr virus or
from mono and it just comes down to a
lymphoproliferative disease going back
and now having looked on it with time we
learned that in fact some of the case
reports do list some GI problems but
that wasn't the major focus because they
were battling the lintel porifera busy
so how do you move forward on this well
we move forward by looking at a bunch of
different bits of evidence we could show
that it was in his mom and since it's on
the X chromosome that kind of made sense
for Nick we went and looked into the
evolutionary conservation so if you look
at that little box on the upper
right-hand side with all the colors
there's a whole bunch of different
species there and you can see that
here's the amino acid sequence the amino
acid c is conserved all the way down to
a fruit fly and only nick still to this
day and his mother as far as we know
carry this one amino acid change now
since she's got two X chromosomes she's
protected from this disease so that was
encouraging and going in and taking a
look at how does it fit into the gut
disease there was some nod signaling it
so there was some interest around
not but Dave Margolis who is our bone
marrow transplant specialist said you
know this is very encouraging but i'm
not going to do a clinical just i'm not
going to make the clinical decision to
do a bone marrow transplant and i will
not transplant him because there's no
evidence that doing this transplant even
though you tell me about the not
signaling is going to resolve the gut
disease you got to show me more and so
this is one of our you know first cases
of how do we deal with this there's
nothing in the literature nick is not
doing well do we pull the trigger on
going after this or not and that became
a major issue as we went down the road
we brought in Jim verb ski and and Jack
ruedas and James then went after and
looked at some of nick's cells and went
after the signaling and was able to show
that the signaling and apoptosis were
clearly off in nick's pbmc s and was
able to show that and finally Dave
Margolis at that along with that
information and that was linked to not
signaling and Nick wasn't doing very
well he would do the bone marrow
transplant and so it ended up happening
then 42 days later after the transplant
Nick was doing well and I will tell you
that we just passed his third year post
transplant and he is resolved of all gut
disease so it clearly worked that
captured a lot of people's imaginations
it was a single it was a single case and
we've men built for word on how to build
a project around a clinic to be able to
do this and so one of the first lessons
that we learned was do you have
physicians who will practice medicine
with the data you collect and analyze
and the corollary to that is what data
that do they require to make a diagnosis
and one of the big challenges if you're
interested in implementing this is
really having a clinical team that's
going to use the information and it
doesn't make a lot of sense to build out
very very sophisticated algorithms if
the clinical team isn't going to use the
data and this is what what in our case
we believe is the biggest challenge of
implementation it's not the sequencing
it's not the data now so yes those are
important but it's how do you
the information and what information do
you get to the physician and I'll talk
some more about that as we go through
the paper was published we had a very
difficult time publishing this um it was
published in genetics and medicine but
because it was an end of one and it was
pretty early in these days we had a
tough time on this if you're having
trouble sleeping at night I guarantee
you that you can fall asleep reading the
paper if you're interested in the more
life events that happen around this a
couple of reporters got their hands on
this early in the process and followed
the case and they reported on one in a
billion which they ended up winning a
Pulitzer Prize for which it's a very
interesting read in terms of what was
the family going on what did the family
deal with and I want to come back to
that a couple more times later because
as we think about actionability what
families think makes a big difference
okay so where are we today well this is
just a little bit of a flowchart about
all the different pieces that go into
this for us and we are as I mentioned
previously you have a for clinic here's
all the steps that we go through in this
it is both cap and clia-certified we
have three clinical geneticists who
focus in this place in this space excuse
me and we have two genetic counselors
one that focuses on adult that's Jenny
Kurtz and the other that focuses on
Pediatrics that's Reagan White than
these individuals then make up the team
that's practicing the medicine everybody
else is involved in supporting those
programs which we'll talk about so one
of the big issues of course is
establishing causality how do you
establish causality this is obviously a
big challenge and the issue that comes
down to unlike in a research project
we're trying to do the following we need
to determine whether this variant in
this gene causes this disease in this
case and that's the fundamental piece
around this and can you develop the data
around that that your team believes and
the clinicians believe and that we're
going to change how we practice medicine
with and that's a pretty pretty big
issue that most people are facing to do
this we have to consider the annotations
and the impact of the variance and the
function of what is impacted I'm going
to talk a lot more about
that obvious questions is that variant
real does the frequency of the variant
match the expected frequency of the
disease is the variant narrow and
they're likely to be deleterious and
function i'll keep in mind that there's
you know a few thousand people that have
been sequenced and most of these people
we don't have disease information on so
you know we're generating data and when
missing data to be able to analyze this
and obviously there's only a handful of
genes that have been effectively studied
to answer this question about the
variant is the function impacted by the
variant associated or associate able
with the phenotype under analysis and
again i take you back to the next story
with xiap once we did this and once we
did find some GI indications in some of
the other case reports and now we were
able to resolve next case it's obvious
that this was the right choice but how
many of your clinicians and those of you
there are clinicians that are listening
how many of you would have made the same
choice and I think that's a really big
issue as we go down the road and as
different clinical societies try to
gauge how do we manage this information
that's going to all continue to happen
and so what's the level of evidence it's
sufficient for clinical reporting
obviously having multiple publications
make sense but what are you going to do
if you have an N of 1 like we did in the
case of Nick so what we do is we break
the evidence levels into a variant
access we have one variant access that's
looking at the phenotype so we need to
look at this so it does a variant
segregate as a cause de phenotype in
question for multiple families well
that's a pretty strong level of evidence
and as we go down this row here you can
see in each level there's less and less
confidence that that allele frequency or
inheritance pattern is likely to cause
the disease so you have that piece of
information and those of you that are
involved in undiagnosed diseases are
involved in this process realize that
the challenge that sounds quite simple
the causative phenotype but in many
instances it's very very difficult to
ascertain what the phenotype is and so
we've had to build out a series of tools
one that we use is called clin minor
which we now have to take the
information
out of the electronic medical records in
many cases we're getting family members
of that are coming in that have massive
volumes of data and how do you get that
data and how do you go through that who
reviews that and how do you get that all
in play so we've had to spend a lot of
time on that as well and that's often
not thought about when we think about
genomic medicine but the phenotype is
fundamentally the driver and I don't
want anybody to think that i'm talking
about genetics alone or genomics alone
is really going to answer the questions
our view is genomics is another lab
value that needs to be put in context of
the case that you're looking at now as
we tossed are talking about secondary
events or secondary indications or
incidental findings depending on what
you want to call it we'll talk about
that a little bit more so the next step
then is to really look at the level of
evidence so you've got does that
mutation seem to play a role as a
causative in multiple families and again
this level of information then helps you
drive down the functional side so you've
got the mutation effects and you've got
its relationship and then you've got the
phenotypes and multiple family members
and what you're trying to do is
integrate all of this information and
really what it comes down to is your
software and your clinical team then
needs to be able to come up with a
prioritization scheme and what are you
going to do with this information as you
go through so the integration then
allows us to place the variance in two
different reporting categories and so we
look at these different categories as
the follow so the previously reported in
a recognized cause of the disorder so we
would make a pathogenic report on that
previously unreported and is a type
which is expected to cause the disorder
recall that likely pathogenic previously
unreported and is a type of a variant
which may or may not be causative of the
disorder that becomes a variant of
uncertain significance or a V us we tend
not to report out fours and five we tend
to stop at the level three which is a
very intimate certain significance and
I'm going to offer to you that our
biggest challenge
right now is we have many different
variants of uncertain significance and
so do others that are out there and I'll
talk a little bit more about that as we
go forward now since then we've put
together a [ __ ] clinical series of
tests here's a bunch of the different
phenotypes we've used this has just been
published in the last month in science
translational medicine that gives you a
lot more details but my only point here
is to illustrate that it's we're using
it across a wide range of different
phenotypes the most important part about
this to be to be clear on that this is
for undiagnosed diseases this is really
where we're focusing our energies on one
side and then we have another side where
there's some executive medicine
activities that are going on we're
trying to understand how do you practice
this in a healthy population which I'm
not going to spend any time on today so
the findings what do we learn so far
around our pilot projects well we've
learned that we can obtain a diagnosis
about twenty-six percent of the time
I'll tell you that in fact yesterday in
the end the previous week we had two
more cases that have been resolved and
I'll talk about that so we're now work
28 cases that we've resolved out of
these 23 we have four additional cases
with the vuss and two of those cases are
the ones that just got cleaned up and
what happened there is there were some
publications that just came out that
actually showed that those jeans and
those variants that we thought were
causal actually were in multiple family
members so we could comfortably make
that as a call the correct standard of
care for those of you that are not
clinical geneticists or aren't in this
space is that for these undiagnosed
diseases that anecdotally we solve them
somewhere between five and ten percent
of the time so increasing that 27 to 30
percent which is what other groups are
talking about that's a big increase in
terms of genetic Diagnostics now I'm
going to argue that because these are
rare variants you simplify the search
space by the fact that they're rare
variants and so I think that's going to
be helpful but the biggest problem we
have is there's not enough data to help
us reduce the number of variants of
uncertain significance and so I think
that's a major area in the field and
I'll talk just a little bit more about
that down the road so
lessons that we've learned around this
is that the data analysis and knowledge
must meet the clinician needs they don't
make decisions the same way and how you
put together your clinical program
around this is critical and this is
absolutely essential as you're building
out your decision trees in your software
to help the physicians use this
information giving them 18,000 variants
or in the case of whole genome
sequencing which it all but nick has
been done with whole genome sequencing
so Nick was sixteen thousand variants
most of our other cases that we're
working with now are about four million
variants so handing a physician team
four million variants is just not
helpful you really have to focus your
energies around that and I'm not going
to move into talking about some of the
relations that you have to think about
or relationships to the data you have to
think about in addition to providing the
clinicians information so problem number
two what data will be returned in here
owns the data and this is an absolutely
essential piece to this because it's
shapes not only what you're going to
give to the physicians but what type of
information that physicians are going to
use and I'll give a very simple example
if the physicians are only going to
return data related to the phenotype you
don't need a very complicated pipeline
if you're not going to follow up you
don't need a very sophisticated data
storage if you're just going to do this
one time you're going to tell them the
data this is related to your phenotype
and you're done again what you have to
save and what you have to do is very
different than if you're going to do
follow-up and also what we've learned is
that are you going to require their
family members to be sequence there are
some people out there that believe we
should only be doing this in trios we do
know from experience that if we had done
this some of our families would not have
signed up to do this we do require in
the case of children that the parents
provide DNA to check where the alleles
come from and to look for a de novo
that's the only thing we require we do
not require the parents-to-be sequence
as I said we do also know that if you
require that in some cases people will
they view that as being research and
while we may all think that research is
fantastic many of these families are
sick and tired of not
having their case resolved and you
research that is another way of not
trying to help their family member so
the ACMG just came out recently with
some recommendations for reporting and
incidental findings or would all refer
to as secondary findings and clinical
exome and genome sequencing they come
out with some pretty strong statements
about what types of data need to come
back I am happy with some parts of this
I was quite concerned that there was
going to be some resistance around
incidental findings or secondary
findings in totality I think the
challenge here is is that making sure
that these data have to go back to the
physician and putting the pressure on
the physician about that relationship
with the parent with the patient excuse
me it's quite challenging what do I mean
by that if the if the patient says they
don't want to know about bracket one and
you could insist on getting the bracket
one data back what does the physician do
does a physician choose not to do that
and so I think we could have a long
discussion and maybe in some of the
questions that will come up there's a
lot of discussion around this and I
think it's it's premature to make
categorical decisions about how we must
do this I think as a field we have to be
careful and really do some experiments
around us and so we've done that we've
been looking at a categorical model of
choice are ephesus find this to be an
acceptable strategy and in Wisconsin if
its diagnostic or a treatable childhood
and we're talking about a pediatric case
we are mandated by state law to inform
the parents of that information optional
disclosures nothing else not an
actionable childhood actionable adult
and the one that really makes people
nervous around this is non actual adult
meaning something like Alzheimer's
something that's not treatable is it the
parents right to get that information
when the child may not want to know that
themselves when they turn 18 and so that
I would agree is a major area of
consideration and so what have our cases
come up with here's the exact data from
13 cases where we looked at the
with only one family the 13 chose not to
go forward with whole genome sequencing
and of the 12 that then when forward
only one chose to take nothing else the
interesting one is over fifty percent
chose to have all data that comes back
so we ask ourselves well is that a good
thing or is that a bad thing so david
beck and some other team members have
been going out and doing surveys when
they give lectures to us the colleagues
that are working in this space and this
paper was recently published and the
argument would be that if we all believe
that ad are actionable shouldn't be
displayed then when we're asked about
our children we should all say no we
don't want that information so what did
we learn it decide well this paper i
think is quite interesting and if you
were to read down through this
forty-four percent i wanted to know
adult not actionable and themselves and
thirty-one percent wanted to know this
about their children that's not too far
off from about the fifty percent that we
saw before and i think this just simply
illustrates that we as individuals and
as parents believe we have the right to
have this information and i think
there's some very powerful information
around that and i'm going to come back
to that again when we talk about
personal utility as part of what's
actionable in with this data set and
something to keep in mind as you go
forward so again i think you can see if
you're going to give back our data or
you're only going to give back what's
required by law makes a very big
difference in your pipeline and your
clinical decisions and what types of
things you have to do and how you want
to build it out and again there's
there's really no rules exactly and how
we need to do that so the lesson we
learned here was the data return rules
impact the data analysis the storage as
do the follow-up plans and i'm going to
argue that the sect that this is really
a big deal and when you're talking about
building out your infrastructure having
physicians is obviously essential if you
don't have physicians that want to do
this you don't really need to worry
about the rest of it but if you do this
is really where you start making
decisions about what's going to impact
your cloths to implement this so problem
number three is what's actionable I've
been using that word back and forth I
think we all would have an opinion about
this and in fact I've been quite
interested in finding out what people
view actionable to me and when I get
asked often as well from our point of
view being medical professionals actual
means is that something we can do about
it that you know why test if we can't do
anything about it there's a fair number
of people that don't buy the argument
that family history is going to be
helpful and this is really going to
change the care so why should we spend
this kind of money when it's really not
going to make a difference and I'm going
to argue and I'm intentionally being
provocative as a way to help everybody
think about this so I'm going to argue
that we do this clinically every day we
test things that we can't do anything
about every single day and I'm going to
just give some examples that I think
illustrate the point only twenty five
percent of our patients with high blood
pressure actually have control blood
pressure and in fact we know very well
that those with high blood pressure
still are dying earlier of end organ
damage even though we claim we can treat
it cancer diabetes and obesity are all
areas where we test we make diagnoses
and we have in often cases minimal
levels of success of being able to treat
yet we don't ask the question is that
worth testing and worth not testing and
I think it's something to keep in mind
and again this is very very personal at
least from our practitioners point of
view should we be doing this should we
not be doing it if we can't change
outcome so here's another case this is
Lillian so Lillian was a 40-week old ex
preemie had a lot of pregnancy
complications she had I a gr she had a
whole host of issues that came out
around her disease process she was not
treated here she wasn't born here
following an emergency section there's
complex phenotypes that you can see here
presented with an infection increased
severity of diarrhea and was in the NICU
for three months and they
went through all kinds of different
events tried to figure out what was
wrong and long story short they were not
able to figure this out so mind you we
started we saw her at four years so this
family had been on one of these
diagnostic Odysseys were they had gone
from Kate from patient excuse me
clinician to clinician Hospital hospital
trying to find an answer around this
after the extensive evaluations in GI we
ended up doing doing whole genome
sequencing and what we found was a
candidate came at variance in three
different genes we were able to exclude
a bunch of these and we were left with
skip to out it had an ultra-rare hat I
showed no frequency data that was out
there and there was another SMB or you
can think of that as a snip snip and an
SMB are the same it's in case it's a
single nucleotide variants as opposed to
polymorphism we prefer that term causing
the formation premature stop it was as
before highly conserved so seemed
logical and then the other was a
canonical novel splice variant that
looked like it caused a frameshift
downstream so it looked like we had
basically found this now the challenge
with this is is there's is this the gene
or isn't it the gene so how would you
take a look at that well of course you
go to the literature and what we found
was 13 papers had nothing to do with
this phenotype in fact looking at this
you wouldn't even think that it was
involved in any of these phenotypes at
all but what was interesting is is that
if you now go take a look at the
molecular biology around this skip to Al
interacts with the TP c37 gene now this
gene has actually been implemented with
a try chloro hep hep a doe and tarik
syndrome one and so we had actually
looked at this gene as a potential
causal of her phenotypes and we had
excluded it based on the testing well
now we have an interesting point of view
well now we have a binding site or a
binding partner to this gene that has
been implicated in something like this
so would you make a diagnosis that skiff
to I'll is actually
causal would you make that a pathogenic
here we've got some evidence now in our
case we said no this is a variant of
uncertain significance because there's
no evidence that this is actually
causing the disease so this was a
variant of uncertain significance for
months it was the top of our list but it
just SAT there we it was categorized as
a variant it wasn't put out there as a
likely pathogenic it was a variant of
uncertain significance and we had
another case you had a lone what
happened then is a paper came out which
were very happy about months later that
this group had actually looked at six
different individuals and indeed it is a
variant that is actually causing this
and they proved that so suddenly the
only thing to change and I mean I say
only in quotes it's a big deal was that
now this paper came out and it was able
to prove the point that this was the
diagnosis and so we gave the parents a
diagnosis it has helped us think about
how we manage the care of this child it
has helped us do it better but there is
no cure for this this is not a Nick
Walker story where we're able to come in
and figure out how to resolve this and
solve some problems and in fact it's
introduced us and the family to have to
think about some other potential places
to worry about down strange so it has
modified care but it hasn't changed a
child's life and so some people would
argue well that's a good deal some
people would say well have you really
have you really changed care and so we
think we have and so there's no cure as
I just mentioned and additional family
members have been tested and of course
for this family since they're a young
couple it could have potential impact
for them downstream when they're
thinking about having other children so
these are ways to think about this all
right so what I want to do is is is have
you listened to the family so this was
obviously as you listen to this was put
on as a marketing campaign for raising
philanthropist or apologize for that in
advance but I want you as the audience
to listen to what the parents say about
the meaning of the sequencing to them so
if you'll play that please don
anyway sister our whole life since
Lillian's been born has been kind of
like a rollercoaster ride she was born
at 30 weeks 1 pound 4 ounces 11 and
three-quarter inches long she was ill
several times in the NICU she was tested
fresh Walkman diamond syndrome she's
been tested for cystic fibrosis she
slowly stopped eating anything by mouth
and we just did tube feedings she's had
three colonoscopy and masteries I can't
even remember all the different things
she's been tested for
too many many institutions they had been
seen by many doctors they've been seen
by geneticists they've been seen by all
sorts of other sub specialists she had
been through so many different tests and
with them all coming back negative I
think that at times that they wondered
if they ever would find a diagnosis she
became sick and fall of 2010 I remember
looking at her one day and feeling like
she was dying in front of me she had
gone from 24 pounds to 18 and they
couldn't figure out what was wrong so
that's when we came the children's you
know the whole concept of the whole
genome sequencing was new to us genome
sequencing is a process where we examine
or we look at for the genetic material
all of the DNA all of the instructions
that a person has its purpose is to help
us diagnose children when we've not been
able to find a diagnosis before many
physicians suspected she might have a
genetic condition she really said many
of the criteria halt the patient who had
an unexplained disorder and for which
there may be potential treatment
strategies genomics is is almost are our
fulcrum if you will to the reach out to
the many many specialties that our
genetics program supports one of the
remarkable aspects of whole genome
sequencing is really the range of
patients that we've been able to help
patients with intestinal problems
patients with immune problems patients
with neurologic problems patients with
cancer the list goes on and on they
could find something that would tell us
why the lien is who she is and what she
has the problems that she has that was
our number one thing anything to give
her a better life
we found the molecular diagnosis for
Lillian through her genomic sequencing
we were just ecstatic I couldn't wait to
pick up the phone I couldn't wait to
call them she's the first child it's
been diagnosed with this in the United
States she's unique the diagnosis is
unique we have an answer it gives
something for the specialists to
continue to look into to see what they
can do to better help us Lillian has
made tremendous progress over the years
every time I see her she's doing better
and better by doing the whole genome
sequencing we don't have to keep
searching if it weren't for Children's
Hospital we're not sure if Lillian would
still be here with us today
okay so several points obviously the
family was happy with this with the
diagnosis and I think two things that
were very important that the parents
said was they have a diagnosis dad said
that and mom said we don't have to keep
searching and I think as we start
looking at personal utility there is
tremendous value around for this family
and I think that these types of
situations and people wanting to know is
going to continue to drive into
direct-to-consumer genetic testing if we
don't pay attention to this and I think
this is really important discussions
that we need to have I'm not saying that
we shouldn't worry about how do we make
diagnoses I'm not saying that we should
turn this into the wild wild west but
what I am saying is is that we have to
look at utility as being more than just
what we can do to help these patients
there is something about having a
diagnosis as you all know that's
meaningful to a family member okay so if
we now continue thinking about this how
you define actionability and what's
actionable and determine when to deploy
clinically is going to have huge effects
on how you build your program if you're
going to really not worried about
anything that isn't druggable that you
can't treat then you don't really have
to spend a lot of time on this if you're
going to really try to go after making a
new diagnosis then you need to think
about this very carefully and in fact
you know we hope you do want to do that
because collectively as I'll talk about
in a few moments we're going to have to
work together to solve these variants of
uncertain significance now what I also
hear over and over and over again is no
insurance company will pay for this
anytime soon this is a letter I can't
tell you the name of the insurance
company that was written to David
Dimmock back in February 23rd of 2011
that says as we have discussed in
situations where you determined that on
average the cost of routine testing will
receive the contract price of whole
genome sequencing we will authorize
whole genome sequence
is a first line clinical test so I'm a
big believer in testing hypotheses so we
asked the question and I'll ask you of
the 12 cases where we were following
this on how many do you think we had
pre-authorization on so just think about
that for a moment typically we get
people saying zero I wouldn't get people
saying 12 which was great because it
turns out that six out of 12 got pre
authorizations I'm going to tell you
that it's not necessarily a slam dunk we
basically are going to the insurance
companies and we're basically arguing
that will start with the gene tasks will
go to a gene panel tasked regard to a
whole exome and then when we don't find
it the last reflexive test we're going
to do is hold genome sequencing or you
can do whole genome sequencing and in
some cases they've really decided that
you know they don't want to roll the
dice it's cheaper to actually do the
whole genome sequencing in advance okay
so I want to summarize and finish with a
couple key points here around what we're
doing so we have a clinically certified
laboratory and analysis pipeline for
whole genome sequencing whole exome
sequencing gene panels and we do
follow-up clinical saying or sequencing
as a validation so we use next
generation for the sequencing and then
we do validation with Sanger sequencing
because of this we actually have the
ability to test any variant or any
combination of variants clinically we
had to figure out how do you put
together a a clinical tests that any
variant that pops up we can actually use
and that's turned out to be a bit of an
advantage for us because we have people
contact us and say hey could you check
this variant in a clinical setting and
the answer is we can do that so that's
been helpful for us to think through
that as I mentioned we've developed a
clinical clinic for adults and children
and our practice setting this medicine
with whole genome sequencing and the
reason we call this personalized
medicine is because the decisions the
families and the patients have to make
is incredibly personal and if you've
been involved in this from the
counseling side then you also know that
this is a big deal for these families
what incidental information do you want
back and we can think about this
esoterically but these are real
questions that people have to make and
not
why we consider this to be personal
because of the nature of the decisions
and the impact on the individuals and
the families we are making a diagnosis
about twenty five percent of the time
it's just bumped up as I told you we've
solved two more cases this week but
between twenty and thirty twenty to
thirty percent is what most undiagnosed
disease programs are talking about
resolving right now and is if you've
heard other people talk about this
they're going to come up with many the
same things that I've told you which is
these variants of uncertain significance
is the challenge we do believe as I've
mentioned to you that actionable does
include personal utility we've had some
very interesting results with our
families and their patients in another
case where the child died and the family
decided not to do a transplant because
the child was going to die independent
of the transplant the transplant was
just going to delay the death the family
were not happy with the diagnosis and
outcome had some relief that it was not
their fault they hadn't done anything
wrong again very much in a personal
utility category I'm going to argue we
have a lot of people that debate whether
you should do it or not do it i'm going
to say d 20 cases at your institution i
will be shocked if you don't find what
we found which is it does have
incredible utility we have also had an
increase in our physicians interest in
this i'm no longer having to go around
on campus trying to convince people to
use this we're now worrying about how do
we implement this across different
clinical lines because now the clinician
the clinician conversations are have you
tried whole genome sequencing and i
think that's been a big change for us i
think you can impact medicine today i
urge you if you're not in a point where
you can think about doing whole genome
sequencing to get people starting to
think about it pick a gene or a panel
but just get started on it if this is
coming incredibly quick look we're not
you know an institution you would think
about doing this with the Medical
College of Wisconsin probably many of
you've never heard of us if we can do
this this is going to happen relatively
quickly and the other part that I think
is important why are we really pushing
this you having your patients sequenced
and we all sharing data is going to be
what's going to be
solutely important in us figuring this
out so here's an example of a case you
can see this case on a nova show called
about understanding your genome where we
were on Nova and we successfully failed
i'm going to say that again successfully
failed to make a diagnosis on our case
48 which down in the lower right hand
corner we didn't make a diagnosis but in
working with the nih through their
undiagnosed disease program they thought
they had a couple of other cases that
had a similar phenotype and long story
short they've resolved this case we
didn't resolve it up front but this is a
success the fact that we had done the
sequencing and they had been involved in
the sequencing themselves they wanted to
do themselves which was absolutely okay
and integrating the data they actually
found it and they were able to figure
this out it's not the same variant but
if you think about it once you know the
gene is causally related now you can go
back in so we've got to be thinking
about this as a community how do we
share this data and because of that
we've now had a diagnosis for case 48 it
is probably not going to change our
ability to treat case 48 but the family
again has consolation and knowing what
the did what the diagnosis is and
knowing what the disease processes and
the functional studies are underway both
in our place and at NIH so why are we
doing this now here's the last case I
want to present to you um this is avery
see an issue presented with poor feeding
and failure to thrive but met early
developmental milestones subsequently
began to fail many tests were performed
nothing abnormal was was identified
after three year three and a half years
it was determined that in fact she had a
treatable disease and she's got some
great outcomes now in that the
neurological degeneration is stopped but
what happened before we can't change and
nobody made a mistake on this it was
just the clinical presentation in her
case didn't suggest that it was the
there's many different gene tests many
metabolic tests that were done and it
didn't show up had we done whole genome
sequencing on her we would have found a
variant and we would have known what was
wrong so the reason we do this right now
on our institution what we're focusing
on is we're really trying to avoid these
types of situations and really trying to
prevent that so that's where we are I
want to close before I start taking
questions to tell you that if you want
to obtain your CMI's you need to go to
this site and pick up that information
go there and go through I think you have
to take some quiz along none so with
that I'm going to close and take
questions I see we have Q and Q neighs
that are on there i will open those up
and start answering questions around
that i'll get through as many as i can
so let me open that here okay so i'm
going to take a couple these questions i
will tell you what the questions are and
then i will try to answer the question
the best I can so since this was the
beginning how did you get insurance
companies to pay for these tasks I'm
going to be completely honest with you
we there was I don't know how old the
age group is that around there but what
we did is that we basically showed them
that you could pay us now or you could
pay us later the old Midas commercial
that we basically tore them that we were
going to nickel and dimed him to death
and we had several cases where we put it
in and it was rejected and we were told
you know please appeal and i'll tell you
i've met with several chief medical
officers for the insurance companies
they're paying attention to this
everybody's just trying to get their
head around this and so it's not a slam
dunk you just submit this and then it
happens it really is something you have
to work through there's some other
questions that are related around us in
terms of costs I'm happy to share with
you the costs we are doing whole genome
sequencing the entire counseling
sequencing analysis data return
incidentals for seventeen thousand five
hundred dollars
90 day turnaround we are doing whole
exomes for 4875 again that's I think
that's a 90 day turnaround as well
there's a question related to who would
pay for Canadians who would come for
care at our institution I don't know
what the answer to that is if there's a
specific case that you're interested in
please feel free to email me Jacob at
MCW edu and we can put you in touch with
that in some cases I'll be completely
honest with you families have decided
that even if the insurance wasn't going
to pay for it they've decided to pay for
it themselves so there are solutions
around that it's not something that I
would prefer but that's kind of where we
are on that bit let's see a couple other
people are agreeing with the generalized
strategy and think it's got some great
potential let's see other questions how
will the diagnosis be impacted by the
Affordable Care Act we have no idea
again I think this is something
everybody's trying to figure out as we
go through you know I'm not sure there's
going to be a solution to that any time
soon it I think we still have to keep
pushing on it to help make it be a
reality another question in terms of
success rates for making a diagnosis is
there a significant difference between
whole genome sequencing and whole exome
sequencing it's a great question the
answer is that we have found in the
eight cases now that have been solved I
believe it's two out of the eight we
would not have identified with whole
exome sequencing now one of the
challenges with whole exome sequencing
is coverage we actually get better
coverage of jeans when we do whole
genome sequencing so it's a little bit
of a hard question to answer so we
obviously get the same data that you get
with whole genome sequencing is you
doing the whole exome sequencing if
you're not familiar with whole exome
sequencing is a pulldown step and that
pull down step has a bias that's
associated this so
the advantage of whole genome sequencing
is that you actually can get some better
coverage and some key genes that are
missing and the whole exome so it's a
little bit of a chicken versus an egg
question the other part that we do do in
each case whether we do the whole exome
sequencing or do the whole genome
sequencing is Liz worthy who's built our
software her team's build something
called gap mine and gap mine actually
goes through and categorizes which genes
are missing which axons and which bits
so we can then go in and if the
clinician team thinks that that's a
that's a major fault then we can go back
in and fix that sequencing so we're
going to us we still think that whole
genome sequencing offers or reflex for
groups that wanna that can get a whole
exome sequence if it doesn't work then
perhaps a whole genome sequencing is
another way to get the insurance
companies to think about this any other
questions out there we're sitting at
five minutes left wait another minute or
so if there's any other questions
otherwise for those of you that are on
thank you so much for your participation
and like I said up there's another one
that's come in so yeah so was their
validation after the treatment with
another whole genome sequence to ensure
that was the SMB and causing the disease
what we do do in all cases we take the
next generation sequencing and before we
report it out we go we validate that
variant in our Sanger sequencing
protocol that's part of our clinical
delivery so part of our cost then
includes validation or verification
maybe would be the right term of the
variance so we do that we do see about a
six percent difference between variants
that we think we're called in in the
next generation sequencing versus the
Sanger so those are validated in that
way I'm not sure if that's what you mean
in some of the other cases we also then
are going in and we're trying to do some
studies around those and we're again
looking to
find other family members that are out
there that have had their genome
sequence to help make the decision I
believe the guidelines right now
although the ACMG is working on this is
that you need to have three unrelated
examples of a polymorphism that's been
associated with the disease there's some
talk of moving that up a little bit
higher and so you need some of the
biology also assigned to that and so we
have some strengths and some specific
areas and in those cases are immunology
clinic as an example we'll go in and do
some gene editing and cells and try to
see if we can prove that particular
variant the key to that though is I only
do those follow-on studies if the
clinical team is willing to make a
diagnosis based on that change if the
clinical team is not willing to make a
diagnosis with a follow-on study then we
declare it as a VOS and hope that
somebody will publish something on that
sooner than later any other questions
next one just came in is what sequencing
platform are we using we have basically
core we have quite a few different
machines we have a 454 we have
aluminized we have a pact bio we have a
my seek and what we're doing the work of
the sequencing on is the alumina hi seek
it's got its good points and it's bad
points around it I think all of the
short read technologies have some
equivalency to them I would like us to
get away from short read technology and
get to a point where we can do de novo
assembly with longer reads which is why
we're looking at the pacbio as a
potential solution I know alumina is
looking at they've got some new
technologies that are out for longer
read lengths so for me it's really read
Lincoln quality in the price point and
so for us alumina has just been a better
solution I'm not saying it's the only
solution i'm just saying that that's the
solution with chosen let's see yeah so
the question is around how do we get the
insurance companies confidence in the
technology we need to look at sequencing
before and after we do have a couple of
studies that are underway to be able to
look at some of those questions about is
it really is it better and that's just
going to take some time and so there are
quite a few groups that are out there
that are waiting to see those data I
think that's going to take a fair bit of
time to convince people I'm hoping that
what will happen is is that we'll get to
a point where the insurance companies
will start to realize and I think cancer
is going to be the first place where
they're going to realize that sequencing
tumors and looking at sequencing of RNA
and coming up with expression profiles
for that is a way to help determine
which drugs the patient should give
since he should get since these are
incredibly expensive drugs I'm thinking
that might help drive that as well I
think it's just the big concern as near
as I can tell is people are worried
about what's going to happen is with the
incidental findings that we're just
going to drive up health care costs
because there's going to be all the
follow-on studies all the fire on
clinical characterisations that are
going to go on and so I think we're just
going to have to prove the point the
analogy I like some of you may not like
it is the MRI when that first came out
there's whole body screening there's all
this other stuff and with time both the
insurers and the practitioners and the
patients actually all three have figured
out what's a better use of MRI and to
some extent I'm afraid we're probably
going to have to do some of that with
whole genome sequencing okay we are at
time so I'm going to close I want to
thank you for your attention thank you
for the questions and hope to see you
out there sequencing clinically soon
thank you very much